change is a good thing and the sponsors
of this next segment chapman automotive
have some big changes on the horizon
here to tell us more is don hamrick he's
the president of nevada operations good
to see you buddy nice to see you as well
how's everything awesome it's great to
have you on the show we've got some big
changes what do you got for us so all
kinds of neat things i mean we just
opened this month a brand new collision
center
and we're very excited about that
state-of-the-art beautiful facility when
you go in you would think it's something
else
it looks like a a you know a ritz
crawled in pretty pretty store for a for
a collision center and then what you're
seeing on screen is our all-new
dodge national ram store and that is
being uh built on the corner of sahara
and boulder and we open that next month
are you ready for that smokes i am ready
that is gorgeous and then a beautiful
facility so we're very excited our team
you know the chapman group has decided
it's really really important that our
employees have a great place to work and
our customers have a great place to do
business so that's going to be the spot
well all your customers are always so
satisfied and your employees are so
happy someone's watching right now
they're looking for a job they want to
get into the business are you guys
hiring we are hiring in order to fill
that space there's 70 000 square feet in
that dealership and the majority of it
is dedicated to our parts and service
we still have a great sales facility but
you know parts and service taking care
of customers after they've purchased
their cars very very important we're
hiring great techs we're hiring parts
counter people uh every job in the
dealership is up so uh there's gonna be
some great opportunities for people
loyalty is big with your customers here
and with your with your employees you
guys are number one for a reason right
well we feel like it i mean you know so
what's happened for us over the years
our employees we we actually have a
magazine called team talk our chapman
talk comes out once a quarter and we
have legends in there these are people
that have been employees of the
dealership for over 20 years of the
company for over 20 years and it's pages
you flip pages and you see these people
so if you start with the chapman team
you don't leave and then our customers
for the third year in a row our
dealership has been recognized as a
walter p chrysler award winner so
this
recognition comes
to a very limited number of stores 3 000
dealerships in the nation only 24 stores
have earned that recognition and for us
it's the third year in a row so we're
very proud of that it's uh and that
comes from our customers our our ratings
from our customers are what determine
whether or not you earn that award last
question and i gotta wrap it up i do
have to talk cars for a second that new
jeep with the v8 with 382 horsepower is
it yeah it's more no no it's uh the 392
is is right at 500 horsepower on the
on the jeep uh wrangler and it's a 392
v8 engine yeah amazing engine they
slipped that thing in there
it's fast it'll climb a wall it is just
a beautiful beautiful rig and so uh
we're selling all those they're special
order only if you want come down to
chapman we'll do a special order for you
and we'll make that happen i love it
thank you so much don thanks for joining
us i can't wait to the dealership is
open i'll be there chapman dodge
chrysler jeep and ram 3170 east sahara
avenue at mojave give them a call at
702-4
las vegas dodge dot com they got special
offers like zero percent financing for
72 months we'll be right back